we can't just kill everyone that's
exactly what we're gonna do we're even now
holy why are you doing this because i want
back in so i need her gone they took ryan
don't you worry i will find your son
we are your heroes we are here to serve
and protect you shepherd they need you now
he said he lives under a pawn shop
in east flatbush hey let her in
they took him dam ryan oh god
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is gonna
be my trailer video for the boys season 2 episode
eight it's the finale but they have been renewed
for season three i'll explain what's going on with
that during the video too if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we'll do a new amazon giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
all your predictions for the finale on the
video so the actual title of the episode
is what i know that's the title of issue 38 of
the boys comic book that's where butcher learns
about huey's relationship with starlight for
the first time and starts to manipulate them
obviously that was plot that they covered early
during season one a lot of the titles of the boys
episodes during season two are titles taken from
comic book chapters but as you've seen a lot of
those chapters don't correspond to the actual plot
of the episodes and usually the titles themselves
have multiple different meanings and references
during the episodes but the footage starts with
homelander landing in a field outside of town that
looks very similar to the area where stormfront
is fighting queen maeve starlight and the rest of
the boys cannot wait to see queen maeve throw down
with stormfront you have to imagine that they're
both about the same power level but stormfront has
a lot of abilities the queen maeve doesn't before
stormfront showed up queen maeve was the second
most powerful superhero in the world next to
homelander homelander is still the most powerful
of all we don't really know exactly how powerful
ryan is but he could become just as powerful as
homelander eventually but you remember a couple
episodes ago where homelander was really pissed
off at stormfront and said you know you told
me that you don't break easily and i've been
thinking about that like he wants to rip her
in half and he could do it if he wanted to
but the thing about queen maeve versus stormfront
is that i feel like even though they're similar
strength levels because of her lightning-based
attacks the only way the queen may withstand a
chance is if she got up in close and got her
in a bear hug some of you have also realized
that there's also a lot of footage from the boys
season 2 trailer that we haven't seen yet meaning
that it's footage from the finale that looks very
similar to where this area they're fighting is
in that you have butcher with a giant assault
rifle charging through the woods looking like
he might be going after homelander or stormfront
and you have homelander floating down from the
sky with this strange sad look on his face what
could possibly cause him to look like that because
he does not care about any of the boys he would
laser them into oblivion and not bat an eyelash
but then you have the footage of them right after
the ending of episode seven arming up butcher
looking like he grabs every single weapon he can
get his hands on even see kimiko walking around
with a giant weapon like it's no big deal but he's
declaring all-out war on the seven kill them all
homeland or stormfront indiscriminately he doesn't
care anymore the way the showrunner explained is
that the butcher's reaction to the disaster in
the courtroom with everyone's heads exploding
is that he feels like he tried to do things the
legit way believing that the government would be
able to fix things serve proper justice he even
gloats to the tv when he sees homelander reacting
to vogelbaum like gotcha now you sucker but
after that mess now he feels like there's no way
the government or any of the legit agency is going
to be able to fix this so he's done doing things
the proper way and now he's going to go back
to what he knows best down and dirty which is
very much butcher's character from the comics and
there's been a couple references to his darkness
in the past and his time in the sas this season
even becca talks about the darkness within him
when they were together before all the drama with
homelander happened she was kind of afraid of the
way he would react to certain situations there's a
darkness in you butcher's character in the comics
is way more hardcore than the tv show version of
butcher in fact they had that whole lord of the
rings reunion with john noble playing his father
in episode vii in the comics butcher actually
pisses on his father's coffin at the funeral so
tv show butcher is a way nicer guy than comic book
butcher some of you probably realized this but
the showrunner said that they wanted to create
this parallel between butcher and homelander
during season 2 like they're two sides of the
same coin they both feel like they can do whatever
they want they don't play by anyone else's rules
but they both have things that they care about
and that they're fighting for for homelander
it's all about his son ryan he desperately wants
a relationship with him and it will do anything to
make that happen he doesn't want to control him
in a sinister way he just wants to be the dad
to him that he never had so he wasn't lying when
he had that conversation with becca about making
sure that ryan didn't grow up being all messed up
when he finally makes it out into the world which
we actually see during the trailer like you see
him pick him up and fly off around all those armed
guards and tanks butcher on the other hand just
wants becca back that's all he cares about but he
also recently has shown how much he cares about
huey like he's the light of goodness shining on
him asking him to do the right thing you also see
becca finally come to the pawn shop where they've
been hiding out i love the way she explains it
too like she basically just ran around flatbush
looking for every single pawn shop trying to
see if they were there how many pawn shops are
there in flatbush but a lot of this footage
also focuses on stormfront her grand plans
to manipulate the public using social media her
cleansing of america than the rest of the world
and then think about what happened in episode
7 her laser focus landed on ryan she even said
that she's gonna be his new mom so it sounds like
she's got this grand plan for ryan as well the big
question now about homelander especially from this
footage in the trailer is what would cause him to
make this sad face of regret and it probably has
something to do with ryan or stormfront butcher or
something related to those characters like butcher
has shown in the past that he doesn't really care
about ryan he's a super butcher hates all supers
and he knows that ryan is homelander's weakness so
he could threaten ryan's life in order to get it
homelander also stormfront could do something to
endanger ryan's life and even though he loves
that sweet sweet stormfront tang homelander
would always choose ryan over stormfront so early
prediction he's either forced to kill stormfront
to save ryan or someone else or he's compelled
into a very darth vader redemption return of
the jedi type of moment like his moment where he
finally does something good like he says in the
trailer we are your heroes we're here to protect
you he actually believes that he desperately wants
everyone's approval stormfront is like the emperor
to his darth vader though pulling all the strings
trying to manipulate him with all the sex she's
the one that's trying to twist him even darker
conversely ryan has also shown that he has most of
if not all of homelanders powers so i would also
love to see ryan accidentally trash someone
at some point that would also probably make
homelander pretty sad like ooh now he's messed
up just like me that's bad you also have all
this footage of a train turning on the seven
giving the boys info on stormfront so that
they'll help get rid of her allowing him a place
back on the seven speaking of which the church of
the collective so many people think that they're
the ones that were really behind all the popping
heads in the courtroom in episode seven and it's
part of their larger plan to influence vaught it's
always possible i'm seriously hoping if that's
true they also found a way to make the fresca
jokes part of that like they laced the fresco with
something that helps them keep tabs on everyone
or some other way and that's connected somehow to
the agent's head exploding randomly in the middle
of nowhere earlier this season the showrunner
was joking a lot about fan theories people had
about all the popping heads he's like don't worry
we pay that off and explain it during the episode
there's also a lot of theories that stan edgar
might have superpowers secretly i don't know if
that's the case otherwise the only real ace he has
up his sleeve because he wields so much authority
is black noir and black noir was taken down by a
freaking almond joy last week so everyone post all
your theories about the finale in the comments
below but quick reminder the boys season 3 will
go into production sometime soon either before
the end of the year or early next year sometime
jensen ackles is going to be playing soldier boy
we saw his statue during episode 7. within the
world of the boys he's basically their parody of
captain america on the avengers like the captain
america first avenger movie within the world of
the show during world war ii he was meant to be
america's first experiment in creating a superhero
just like stormfront became the first superhero
they created with compound b there's been all
kinds of rumors about them doing a plot with him
that extends into present day during the comics
soldier boy was supposed to have died a long time
ago so it sounds like they're going to be changing
some of the soldier boy story line for season
3. but for those of you that spotted it earlier
there was also talk about jeffrey dean morgan also
former supernatural alumni playing a character
during season three but the showrunner didn't say
who that would be but my video for the boys season
two finale will post on friday just like normal
as long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see that video when i post it
leave all your requests in the comments below
i will do some videos for the boys season 3
after i do my finale video too everyone
trying to keep the dream of herogasm alive
well you wait for everything click here for
the boys season 2 episode 7 and click here to
learn all about marvel bringing a bunch of andrew
garfield spider-man stuff back for spider-man 3.
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight